[Music]
hello thanks for attending the emergency
meeting have you ever wanted to pet
chica
of course you have just look at her
she's adorable don't get on her bad side
or disappoint her
she won't be happy about that the mini
choose your own adventure about petting
chica is available for members of the
channel
right now if you click the join button
or the link in the description below you
can find out how to become a member
today
now the reason that i'm telling you
about this is number one to announce the
first piece of content in my
big ass bake sale of content but also to
ask for your help
if you didn't know heist2 is currently
in production
and it's going along great i wrote it
and that's good
unless you ask the people that are in
charge of the budget in which case me
writing it is bad because
i made it too big and we are currently
over budget now this is where you guys
can help because the membership system
it kind of works differently depending
on the channel you get to set your own
things
but for me i always use the membership
system to fund the bigger projects that
i make
on the channel for everybody it has
helped fund wilford mother loving morph
stash
damien the first heist with markiplier
and a bunch of other bigger projects
that i've put out on this channel and
that's great it's been a fantastic
system so far
but i always want to kind of push myself
to make
more things which is why i am tempting
you today
with a buffet of baked content with
decadent aromas that are wafting through
the air
towards you to tempt you to see if you
want to become
a member today because i'm not just
going to make this many choose your own
adventure about petting chica
i'm going to be making a ton of more
content
that you can enjoy if you become a
member today
on top of that there's other perks that
you can get you can click on the join
button down there or the link in the
description
and you can see all the different perks
that you would get you'll also notice
that there's different
tiers of membership i want to tell you
very clearly right now that there's
no difference in the amount of things
you get at the bottom tier versus the
top tier the only difference
is for big dick moneybags that feel like
they want to contribute
more and i appreciate that but do
understand that there's no difference
the content is the same and if you want
to get out of the membership afterwards
that's fine in out help don't help
it's all good to me it's all fine i'm
okay with any of it because the fact
that you're willing to help at
all is fantastic and i greatly
appreciate it
so thank you everybody that has been a
member already there's been some people
that have been a member for over two
years
there's this special badge that you get
it's like a rainbow badge by your
username
if you've been there for two years and
there's different level ups of course
but
like the fact that people have been
helping me make projects like this for
the whole channel
for over two years is amazing and i am
eternally grateful to those that have
and i will be grateful for anybody that
does become a member and i will still be
grateful for anyone that can't become a
member i get that
it's totally fine i understand and i
want to help make these cool projects
because i want more people to be able to
enjoy it and i also want people to
realize
that youtube can be an incredible
platform for creativity
if the people are able to help people
make
cool things so that's about it the bake
sale is on and i will be spending the
next few weeks making
tons of content tons of content the pet
and chica simulator which i highly
recommend checking out it's adorable
but honestly it wasn't that tough to
make it took some filming some editing
but at the end of the day
it's a bite-sized piece of content that
i can make
and mass and bake up huge trays
of decadent content for you to enjoy to
tempt you it's fun to see a challenge
and kind of rise to it and i don't want
to give you nothing for something so i'm
going to give you something
for something so that we can give
everybody something else
so in case it wasn't clear heist 2 will
still be available for everybody
you don't need youtube premium you don't
need a membership to watch heist too
just like you didn't need it for high
school markiplier
damien wilford mother loving war session
all those other videos that i've made
because the generosity of the members
helps fuel the creativity
in this chaotic brain of mine and the
newest bit of creativity
is this bake sale and petting chica
and a day in the life of markiplier
where you get to choose my routine and a
pov car wash where i might be
in a bikini or something washed in your
car and you get to choose
that sounds tempting right a lot of
really good ideas coming out
if you can't become a member and you
have ideas for things that you want me
to make
write them in the comments below my
members have already started coalescing
a big list of ideas for things that they
want to see made
and more things that i can add into the
bake sale there's community-made stuff
if you can make things that can be a
part of it
please do i welcome it and i appreciate
it so
try out being a member today if you can
click the button down below that says
join or there's a link in the
description click it
check it out be tempted walk into the
tent
give it a whiff look at the brownies the
cookies the muffins
all of these decadent baked goods
there's carrot cake
there's ice cream cakes melting fast and
right now if you become a member
there's also other member only videos
that you've probably never seen before
and you get to pet chica which is
probably the more important thing so
check it out thank you everybody so much
for attending this emergency meeting and
yeah that's pretty much it
join button down there link in the
description see you later
bye